this morning just days after an armed
Rebellion Russian President Vladimir
Putin spoke in moscow's Cathedral Square
praising his country's Security Forces
for stopping what he called a civil war
last night in his first public
appearance on TV since the weekend
Revolt Putin called the organized
organizers Traders Ian Lee in Ukraine
has more
the failed Mutiny last weekend still
hangs heavy over Russian President
Vladimir Putin
he lashed out again at Wagner's
leadership on state TV last night saying
they would be punished for the Rebellion
but he also courted The Rankin file
calling many Wagner Fighters Patriots
who are misled and invited them to join
the Russian army the ministry of Defense
announced today that Wagner will now
hand over its heavy weapons Putin's
speech last night followed an audio
recording from Evgeni pragosian who has
not been seen publicly since Saturday
the Faulkner Boston and I trying to
overthrow Putin saying his fight was
with the country's military leaders who
he accused of failing to win the war in
Ukraine
Putin tried to mask the uncertainty in
the country last night with images that
he's firmly in control he met with his
security Chiefs including Minister of
Defense Sergey shoigu and thanked them
for their support
State media portrayed a return to
business as usual with scenes of
Battlefield victories in Ukraine but
Saturday's Mutiny shook cracks in
Putin's strongman image Wagner troops
quickly seized the city of rostov and
the Russian military Southern command
then headed toward Moscow it took a deal
brokered by the president of Belarus to
stop his deadly Advance toward the city
Wagner Fighters would be pardoned
and progosian would go into Exile in
Belarus
Putin also took aim at the West telling
his people that Russia's enemies wanted
them to choke on Bloody civil Strife on
Monday President Biden distanced the
United States from the Insurrection
Putin no excuse to blame this on the
west or to blame this on NATO
we made clear that we were not involved
we had nothing to do with it this was
part of a struggle within the Russian
system
U.S officials tell CBS News another 500
million dollar Aid package to Ukraine
will be announced today that'll include
Bradley and Striker armored fighting
vehicles
equipment that Ukraine desperately needs
as it continues to take ground in its
counter-offensive
and today we're learning a plane linked
to Wagner boss yevgeni pragosan has
landed in the Belarus capital of Minsk
no word yet if he was on board Vlad
Ian Lee and Ukraine for us Ian thank you
very much